foreign
[Music]
thank you
questions
[Music]
foreign
do I sound good oh there we I am there I
am okay
good evening glad to see you guys all
here welcome to the table those of you
are joining us online we're glad that
you are here with us as well hope you
guys had a wonderful Thanksgiving
um it is one of those times where we are
now beginning to somewhat transition
into the next big season that's coming
up right behind right behind that and
what's one kind of a great space to be
in is that it already looks Christmassy
in here like I don't know about you but
as soon as Thanksgiving was over the
Christmas tree went up in my house it
was kind of crazy so it was just kind of
like oh we did not stop to breathe at
all between one transition
so anyway but we are about to kick off
um the Advent season
um one of the dates when you want to
make sure that you keep in mind is that
the um
Christmas Eve which is going to be the
24th obviously that's a Saturday this
year uh we are going to be participating
with Pleasant Valley uh they do a candle
lighting service actually very beautiful
it's amazing kind of a ceremony if
you've not ever participated and had
that here and participated that with
them it's a lot of Christmas carol
singing it's just a great service just
to be a part of so I must only want you
to
stop by be a participate with that with
us as well that will start at 4 30. so
just kind of keep that in the back of
your mind
um as something we're going to be doing
the other thing I want to bring to your
attention is that we are also wanting to
expand and add a second class of kids to
our kids ministry so we do have like
kindergarten and sixth graders in the
same room
and that has some unique interesting
Dynamics as you can probably imagine and
I'm going to tell you kids and history
is a lot of fun and I know you know that
because we hear how much fun
kids ministry us on a regular basis so
what we're looking for is um for you to
volunteer like once a month just so we
can help with that transition that would
be absolutely amazing if that's
something you're interested in if you
could let Brett know that would be
helpful of course from grab Brittany
that would be awesome but yeah we would
love to have some people to kind of step
in to help kind of make that transition
for everybody
so with all of those announcements out
of the way
let's pray and we'll get started
Lord thank you so much for bringing us
here together thank you for again for
the space this opportunity to be
together
um it's I pray that you just start
portraying our hearts and Minds for this
upcoming season just all the different
things that we have going on
we work and family and all the things
that preparing because we know that we
this next part of the last year can be
very busy we don't want to forget
the purpose that we have in you and who
you have called us to be
I pray that you open our hearts and
Minds to our the worship tonight to the
message that's going to be shared in
Christ and I pray amen
all right if you guys would go ahead and
stand with us we're going to get started
with some worship
and I just hope that as we go through
this set tonight that you if you are
feeling alone or isolated or or
if there are areas that you're just not
finding
um success in or that you're trying to
overcome I hope that tonight in this
worship set that you feel less alone
that you feel like there is a God that
is on your side who is with you who
loves you
so let's sing this all together
[Music]
I could just stay right where I am and
hope to feel you hope to feel something
again
[Music]
I could hold on
I could hold on to who I am and never
let you change me from the inside
that could be safe I could be safe here
in your arms
[Music]
you have called me higher you have
called me deeper and I'll go where you
will lead me Lord you'll Lead Me
[Music]
I could hold on
I could hold on to who I am and never
let you change me from the inside I
could be safe home I could be safe here
in your arms
[Music]
boy
you have called me higher you have
called me deeper
[Music]
that will be yours
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I will be yourselves
[Music]
where you will be those
you lead me
[Music]
all right kids you guys are dismissed to
go to your classes
are going to move into the prayers of
the people so if you're joining us
online feel free to leave
um your request in the comments or if
you're in the room to speak it out loud
we would like to Bear each other's
burdens together as a community
[Music]
foreign
can you guys read this aloud with me
Jesus for the city of Sachse Texas and
for every city and community and all
those who live in them we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
we pray to you I'm sorry for the Good
Earth that you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old for the old and
the sick for the Widow and the orphan
for the injured and the suffering we
pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and for all who remember
and care for them we pray to you Lord we
know that you love us and that you hear
us so we lift these names and situations
up to you
[Music]
thank you
for the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts we pray to you
that they may have life and light
healing and Hope
and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
my joy
you are my song
[Music]
the one I'm drawing from
where
else would I go surely surely my God
[Music]
love to dance
me
Your Love defends me
[Music]
up today
night after night
I will remember
you're with me
[Music]
[Applause]
the strength of myself
[Music]
thank you
you're my portions
[Music]
strength of my soul
[Applause]
[Music]
life I'm all alone yeah
salvation
[Music]
today
you're my fortune myself just lift our
voices up
[Music]
you're my portion
my salvation we see
[Music]
my salvation
it's good
[Music]
thank you for being a god who's on our
side
a God that we can trust
[Music]
thank you that your love doesn't run out
God I elope to you
I won't be overwhelmed
give me visions
[Music]
to see things like you do God I look to
you you're where my help comes from
give me wisdom
[Music]
you know just what to do
that I love to you
I won't be overwhelmed
[Music]
give me vision
to see things like you do God I love to
you
you're where my home comes from
give you wisdom
[Music]
you know just what to do and I will love
you Lord my strength
yes I will love you Lord
my shield
yes I will love you Lord by Rock
forever all my days
[Music]
give me wisdom
to see just what to do
[Music]
forever all my days
Hallelujah
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
I lift up my eyes to the hills where
does my help come from my help comes
from the Lord the maker of heaven and
Earth he will not let your foot slip He
Who Watches Over you will not Slumber
the Lord will keep you from all harm he
will watch over your life over your
coming and going both now and forever
let's sing that one more time Hallelujah
Hallelujah
[Music]
hallelujah
oh Hallelujah
praise
[Music]
forever all my days
foreign
God coming out of a week where there was
a lot going on
and I'm sure like so many other people
some family drama and some interesting
relationship Dynamics and
all the things that come along with the
holidays God
I'm grateful that you can see things
clearly even when I can't
God that you are trustworthy and we can
look to you
and believe that you have hope for us
even when things seem hopeless
that you have a Way Forward
when it seems like there is no way
forward
that you are a redeemer when things seem
over
when they're at their darkest
you are the light of the world
you are the peace that passes
understanding
you are a Waymaker
and God I hold those promises in my
heart tonight believing not just for me
and for my family but for us and our
families and our community
for our relationships God
[Music]
that you make a way where there seems to
be no way
[Music]
that you love us when we are at our
worst
that you're not ashamed of us
you're not leaving us behind
but you are a faithful father and friend
to us
[Music]
God would you give us Vision to see
things the way that you do
would you give us wisdom
to know the right way to live
[Music]
and would you give us hope as we enter
this Advent season
hope of the world Jesus God With Us
would you be our hope
guide us and direct us
[Music]
we love you God
and we do look to you
show us your way
[Music]
it's in Jesus name we pray all these
things amen
[Music]
that's the end
[Laughter]
would you guys greet the people around
you I don't know if y'all are just
messing with me now or what's going on
go ahead and welcome the people around
you and then Brett will start the
message
all right all right well good evening
grace and peace it's so good to be with
all of you and uh my name is the Brett
and the pastor here and
um man I'm just I'm so grateful to be
together and uh and I want you to know
that you are wanted you're welcome here
um as always that includes those joining
us online so glad you're with us and
anyone here who is new thank you for
um just walking through those doors
I know I say this for well if you're new
you don't know I say this but I say it
almost every week that it takes a lot of
Courage
um it's especially depending on your
story
you know maybe a few folks walk through
those doors for the first time boldly
and confidently
um not many though honestly I mean I'm
you know like a pastor when I go visit a
new church or like you know occasionally
I'll go like to like a Sunday morning
something and I'm like I'm like a little
I don't know like a little lamb just
like okay oh my gosh I hope they don't
they're gonna do I look weird did I
dress right you know whatever I don't
know
um it is it can be really challenging so
all to say I'm just I'm really really
glad um that you're here with us so I
also hope everyone have a good
Thanksgiving
didn't eat too much
yeah
um yeah
I know it's all so delicious I have one
of my beliefs about Thanksgiving is that
it should be unhealthy food
is anyone with me on this I don't know I
mean I've definitely had healthier on
the side of thanksgivings and it's like
I mean it's great it's fine but man
butter just makes everything so
delicious like just like this these are
the best vegetables I've ever had what's
the secret ingredient you know butter
and salt that's why it's awesome so uh I
hope you had plenty of butter and salt
all right I probably shouldn't say that
but
um so as Mindy mentioned it is uh the
season of Advent
and that's true for churches um all over
the world and uh just a few times a year
we join what's called The Church
calendar
um where Church calendars can vary like
a little bit from like Catholic to maybe
Methodist Presbyterian you know there
are little differences but oh you know
generally there's like certain times of
year where for example it's like you go
into like the season of Lent leading up
to Easter and you have after that like
Easter tide and
um you know there's like a few big ones
and one of them is uh is advent
that of course kind of leads into
Christmas so for those who maybe aren't
super familiar
um Advent comes from the Latin Adventist
you all knew that
um the I mentioned it last year don't
you remember
um it comes in Latin Adventist which
means arrival and so it's basically it's
what's kind of interesting that it's
sort of like lint isn't quite the same
as Easter
um instead it's that season of
preparation for Easter and resurrection
and everything kind of Advent similar in
terms of it's not necessarily
um
just purely a celebration of Christmas
and a celebration of of Christ
Incarnation
um really it's really a season of
preparation for that so it's generally
um churches have tended to talk about
um all of the ways that well adventus
God arrives the way God has arrived in
Christ through
um what does Ricky Bobby say a little
baby in the manger right you've got kind
of that way and then that's of course
like the one of the or probably the
primary Advent you know like way to talk
about Christ's arrival but there's
others the way
um God continues to arrive and show up
through the Holy Spirit
and as we talked about last week through
Christ's expanding body uh as he um
connects and meets all of us and then
the way God will
um arrive at um Christ's second coming
when God is all in all so that's kind of
the the general themes of like that's
what um sort of advent is uh is about so
the title of my message this first
Sunday in Advent is smile
it's Advent
it's okay you can do it don't worry so
if you you still had frowny faces smile
it's Advent uh so our scripture is
Matthew 24
42-44 and what's kind of cool about you
know joining the church calendar is uh
it like there's prescribed readings you
know so there's like four I get four
scriptures to choose from each week and
then I just roll with whatever it is you
know so this is the one that jumped out
of me so we'll just hope it's the Holy
Spirit leading me we'll see uh so it
says this Matthew 27 verses 42-44
therefore keep watch
because you do not know on what day your
Lord will come but understand this if
the owner of the house had known at what
time of night the thief was coming
he would have kept watch it would not
have let his house be broken into Jesus
said so you also must be ready because
the son of man this is a title Christ
often used to refer to himself the son
of man will come at an hour when you do
not expect him
now
um I don't know about you uh but
passages when I was younger you know
passages like this one which is sort of
talking about
um Christ the what's known as the second
coming the when God is all in all at the
end of all things
um this was like this passages like this
gave me a little bit of anxiety you know
just this whole idea of Jesus is coming
back
and I gotta be ready
and I don't want to miss it
and I'm a little worried that I will and
so I was a child of the 80s and really
from my memory more than 90s and this
was like um going into the early 2000s
like this was like the height of
um kind of evangelicalism like there we
had the books all the Left Behind books
some of you might be familiar and then
you have all the movies
huge hit I don't know oh maybe not
um at least in my wing of the world
those were like everything you know and
so I think all of this this is kind of
the theme and it's just I don't know it
kind of got me uh a little bit worked up
I think kind of rereading the passage I
think it's all that Thief language is
kind of part of it you know like I'm
coming like a thief in the night you
know I'm just like oh
he's coming like a rapper like a like a
robin murderer or something I don't know
it's just I think it just got me so kind
of weird now rereading it um as an adult
now I realized like well it's kind of a
misreading in the sense of the metaphor
he's using here just it's about robber
as in the unexpected nature of a robbery
right he's not saying like I'm coming as
a thief and murderer in the night get
ready you know like no no he's just
saying like in the same way you don't
schedule out your robbery we wish we
could do that you don't get to do that
right don't say like honey remember
Thursday 2 30 a.m We gotta be ready we
gotta stay up shotgun in hand like the
Texans on our couch right you don't just
you don't get that's not how it works
right you don't get to plan it out and
similarly uh Christ is saying hey you
don't know
um when I will arrive uh and I
now having said that
um what I want to do this kind of in
this message specifically but really
with Advent as a whole is um kind of
help us recover it which is why I titled
this you know smile it's Advent because
um I I want us to
kind of begin reimagining the Advent
theme a theme that there's like this
little phrase in scripture
um that talks about the arrival of God
it's it's come Lord Jesus I want us to
start to reimagine that
um not as something dark and Sinister
um but actually is something wonderful
and good not something not a phrase that
makes us like cringe and Terror like
he's coming like a thief in the night
that was actually a movie I I don't
remember if I saw the whole thing but
they made this movie a thief in the
night and it was all you know the kind
of spooky uh weird Left Behind stuff
um
and I want us to start reimagining this
not as something that makes us cower in
fear in a word we might be left behind
um but rather something that makes us
lift our heads up high in other words
come Lord Jesus is not a statement shot
through with anxiety
come Lord Jesus needn't to be tinged
with fear come Lord Jesus is not a
threat like he's coming so get right
with God or else you know no it is well
it's supposed to be a cry of confident
hope like that's the heartbeat of it
this is what we're actually supposed to
be doing right it's this trust that
Christ was present in the Incarnation
Christ is present through the Holy
Spirit and Christ will be present in his
fullness when God is all in all at the
end of all things you might say or
really in a way it's sort of like the
beginning of all things this is
um this is our hope and this is why the
gospel is not bad news
right the gospel is good news it's
strange though for all of our talk about
the gospel it's good news the good news
of Jesus you know it's like gets
preached so often as bad news it's like
the bad news with most or the good news
with mostly bad news it's the strange we
gotta I don't know we gotta keep working
this Christian theology we gotta keep
reading our Bibles getting this right so
um now having said this here at the
table we speak quite a bit about
Christ's Incarnation
um and it gets a lot of play you know
Advent and then we talk probably even
more than that all the time about how
Christ is present to us day in day out
like that's like 90 of those sermons so
uh tonight I wanted to um focus on uh
this last way that Christ arrives in his
second coming and kind of just be we'll
ask the question like what is this all
about and really furthermore what about
Those portions of the New Testament that
make it do
make it sound like bad news especially
for those unbelievers they're gonna get
what's coming to them you know all that
um like what do we what do we what do we
make of that what do we what do we do
with that so all right so um with that
in mind let's start the way we're going
to kind of frame this I'm going to ask
four questions and then offer answers
hopefully the answers suffice we'll try
so number one what is the second coming
of Jesus all about well in short the
resurrection of Jesus was kind of a big
deal
and uh because of this like it's real it
really has changed everything I think
maybe as Christians we get so familiar
with these ideas like oh yes Christ you
know he came Among Us you know God came
Among Us lived a life was crucified uh
you know died was buried and rose again
and yeah it's interesting you know like
but we don't it's almost like we don't
experience the shock of it anymore you
know what I mean like oh my gosh oh my
gosh the Son of God died was buried and
then rose from the dead now you're free
to like not believe that right you could
be like I just find that far-fetched um
it'd be a little strange to be a
Christian and say that but you know you
can do that but if we're gonna accept it
if we're gonna say like okay yes
like I'm trusting that that is true you
know okay well then again that's that's
kind of a big deal and and it changes
things for us and it changes how we view
the world how we imagine Our Lives I
mean um if you think of it for example
all the fear in the world you know and
and from that fear all the anger and the
hatred like when you think of the cross
of Jesus it's like all of that you think
it's all the like dark kind of spiritual
Powers working behind the scenes of
history and then it's just Humanity at
our absolute worst like you think of the
Cross it's just Humanity at our worst
it's it's um our hatred it's our
religious kind of um worse it's our
political social worst it's um it's our
violence and our torture and I mean it's
just it's it's awful right
and but but the beautiful thing is that
the grave could not hold him down
Christ has risen
in in this like the principalities and
Powers have been defeated
and and if you think about like kind of
where this goes Christ now ascends and
then he's present to all of us and this
is a massive rupture in history it's
like uh one of the most most Wild
Wonderful most unforeseen stories you
could ever imagine
now the good news is though it doesn't
just stop there like oh well
good for Jesus he's such a Victor you
know
um
actually First Corinthians 15 uh versus
50-58 uh and I'll read it in the message
it's a paraphrase of the Bible Paul
unpacks what it means for us
he says this so I need to emphasize
friends
that our natural Earthly lives don't in
themselves lead us by their very nature
into the kingdom of God because their
very nature is to die so how could they
match us how could we naturally end up
in the Life Kingdom he says but let me
tell you something wonderful a mystery
I'll probably never fully understand
we're not all going to die but we're all
going to be
changed you hear a blast to end all
blasts from a trumpet in the time that
you look up and blink your eyes it's
over on signal from that trumpet from
Heaven the dead will be up and out of
their graves beyond the reach of death
never to die again at the same moment
and in the same way we will all be
changed in the resurrection scheme of
things this has to happen everything
perishable
taken off the shelves replaced by the
imperishable this Mortal replaced by The
Immortal then the Thane will come true O
Death swallowed by triumphant life who
got the last word o death O Death who's
afraid of you now because it was sin it
was sin that made death so frightening
and it was law code guilt that gave sin
its leverage its destructive power but
now when a single Victorious stroke of
Life all three thin guilt death are gone
they're gone the gift of our Master
Jesus Christ oh thank God Paul's
preaching huh I don't have to breathe I
just read it that's all I have to do
right
verse 58 with all this going for us my
dear dear friends
stand your ground don't hold back throw
yourselves into the work of the master
confident that nothing you do for him is
a waste of time or effort
you see what God has done for his son
Jesus Christ in Resurrection he has
promised to one day do
not only for you
and for me
but for all of creation
Romans 8 22 States all creation groans
groans like a woman in childbirth
waiting for the day of her Redemption
and who could disagree
from the war-torn cities of Ukraine
we hear the groaning
do their bodies not cry out for
Resurrection
to the child suffering abuse or neglect
in our town
does their little body not cry out for
Resurrection
to those Swept Away by natural disasters
do their bodies not cry out for
Resurrection
to those murdered at Club Q in Colorado
do their bodies not cry out for
Resurrection
yes
you see it's true that there is goodness
and Beauty in this world but we all know
there is also despair
and pain and hellish
suffering
but God's Great promise
our Christian hope
is that what God has done for his son
Jesus Christ he will one day do for you
and for me and for all of creation and
this is why I say
smile
it's Advent and sometimes it's smiling
through the tears
amen like because because we are not yet
there just to be clear I'm not saying oh
Christ has risen and so everything's
Rosy right it's like clearly not
clearly not
but our Christian hope is that one day
God really will be all in all
that we too will receive Resurrection
bodies will be healed and that's what
the second coming of Jesus is all about
and that's good news but it leads pretty
naturally into our second question which
is why is it taking so long
yeah that's a good question
um because you mean I'm imagining you
might say like I I agree friend this
world is is screaming out for
Resurrection oh yes
but what is the delay why is it taking
so long there's um a wonderful
Theologian named sergius bulgalkov quite
a name huh sergius bulgakov
um Russian Orthodox uh Christian and he
says this the goals of God in other
words like the the Telos
um the purpose the end point of God
are unalterable and irrevocable
but the paths to them to those goals can
differ
and these differences in essential for
the whole can turn out to be essential
for individual Destinies and
achievements in other words bulgakov is
naming where we are headed oh it's set
we are talking about the restoration of
all things and all bodies I'm talking
like plants and and animal and mineral
and human I mean all of it right it's
the it's the healing of the cosmos this
is like the great Christian hope so
that's where we're headed
but what bulgar cop names is
that's unalterable that's irrevocable
irrevocable but how we get there the
exact timing and how that all plays out
you know like that's that seems to be
some sort of a dance
between
The God Who is love and him patiently
working with Humanity he um names as an
example a passage we talked about a
story really we talked about a month ago
the story of Jonah and you'll recall uh
that God tells Jonah you know you
preached to the nunavite the city you
tell them 40 days and I will destroy
this city of Nineveh and there's like no
um
no kind of way out that's the end
there's no like Clause like well but if
you know no no it's just 40 days and
I'll destroy this city
and sure enough though the people repent
and suddenly God's like okay never mind
you know it's like what do you mean
that's biblical prophecy that's the word
of the Lord he can't go back on you even
gave 40 like exact timeline
apparently God is uh more creative more
compassionate more patient than we are
um now I think this kind of leads the
third question which is isn't this delay
of the resurrection of the cosmos of all
things
um isn't this super discouraging
and you know maybe I'm weird honestly
um
I think I'm just glad that there's any
hope or plan at all like I like I'll
take that you know maybe I guess maybe I
don't know how Outsiders you know like
folks who aren't Christians maybe how
they might View
me us like even this message you know
like oh you starry-eyed Christians you
know look at the world it's just hellish
suffering this is all there is you know
um maybe I don't know maybe does come
across sort of sort of starting at
Starry Eyed and I even like this this
faith in God you know
um
but when I think of the alternative sort
of just a creeping
um like a nihilism like a
meaninglessness just a pointlessness to
everything it's just hellish suffering
and then that's it
like when I think of the alternative
that
I don't know how everyone's not a
Christian I guess or at least I'm
religious tradition I really and I say
that pretty honestly like I don't
totally get it
um I've I will take the hope I'm rolling
with it like I'm like yes okay yesterday
men so hey it's taken a few thousand
years fair enough maybe it'll take a few
thousand more I don't know I just I'm
just trusting that the goals that tell
us the purpose of God are unalterable
and irrevocable
and as the famous little book of Rob
Bell says love wins I'm just wrong with
that I'm like yep rolling with that
that's my that's that's my hope that's
the great um Christian hope and this is
why I think Paul says you probably
caught it there at the very end of that
long passage from First Corinthians 15.
he says with all this going for us right
like the healing the restoration of all
things with all of this going for us my
dear friends stand your ground don't
hold back throw yourselves into the work
of the master confident that nothing you
do for him is a waste of time or effort
in other words if Resurrection like if
that's where we're headed well then my
goodness Every Act of Love Every Act of
service or kindness or goodness or
Justice or peacemaking like it's all
trying to get us oriented towards where
God's headed like that's you know it's
not a waste it's not pointless it's it's
not stupid right like there's I think
that's actually a source of tremendous
hope and energy
so while I have my days you know I do
have my desk
um on the whole I'm I'm uh I'm trusting
that God's up to something good
uh now this leads to the fourth question
you might say well that's all well and
good
what about the people who are simply
judged and then go to hell come Lord
Jesus doesn't sound like good news for
them
excellent point
um
excellent point you know I think in ways
this is part of a much longer
conversation it's like a sermon I have
to preach maybe once or twice a year
we'll probably get to it in 2023.
um but it's kind of suffice it to say
while I do believe that Christ
does speak a word of of judgment over
everything
evil and corrupt
and horrible in the cosmos I I believe
that ultimately the even the scriptures
where it speaks about the fire
a fire will come upon the Earth
or even the fire of of gehenna
of what we kind of call an English hell
um I I don't think that is just the
Furious
um hatred and Venom of God getting back
at all of the bad people
um I think if you look at scripture as a
whole
those fires are actually a purifying a
refining fire that that's burning away
everything that holds us back from God
and and so while I think
um you know I'm not like rejecting those
verses that carry a certain negative
connotation of the day of the Lord
um what I'm saying is we've often read
those as like God's final word when as
Carl Bart says God's no is always
followed by his yes
and because of all the evil and horror
that we were all nodding our heads to
earlier
I do think there has to be a no spoken
right not in rejecting people
but rejecting what we do
in the the horrendous evil we're capable
of so God has to say no but I think it's
a no that's followed by a yes
just like you know you think of like the
discipline of a loving parent you know a
good loving parent doesn't just like let
the kids run amok you know like there's
discipline it's like nope you said I say
that a lot as a parent actually I'm
gonna think of it nope but most my most
famous popular word in my house nip nope
no nope right and I think this is sort
of the picture of God like no no no
[Music]
but why do you say the no so that you
can follow it with a yes there's a
passage um I'll close with this this is
um First Corinthians 3 11 through 15.
it's not upon your on the slides because
I added this last minute I thought yeah
somebody there's some folks here they
need a scripture you know to kind of
unpack this it's not enough for me to
just say hey trust me it's in the Bible
you know so I'll read you scripture
First Corinthians 3 11 through 15.
says for no this is Paul for no one can
lay another Foundation beside the one
laid down which is Jesus the anointed
he's talking about like the foundation
of our life now if on this Foundation
One erects gold or silver or precious
stones would hay straw
each one's work will become manifest for
the day will declare it
because it is revealed by what
by fire
it is revealed by fire
in other words everything in our life
it is
either precious stones diamonds like how
much are diamonds impacted by fire
not much right they're like no this is
not a big deal for me
you know but what about um grass
doesn't fare so well in the fire does it
and in Paul's naming you can think of
like how we live
as either diamonds and gold that's
actually purified or refined by the fire
or it's revealed as just a bunch of BS
you know like it was nothing it was just
straw it was like stupidity I just
watched a lot of Netflix that's all I
did with my life you know I was like we
kind of know like yeah there's a way to
waste your life you know
is revealed by fire and the fire will
prove what kind of work each person's is
verse 14. it's the work that someone has
built endures
They will receive a reward if anyone's
work though should be burned away he or
she will suffer loss and yeah here's the
key line and yet
shall be saved
this is why I'm hopeful and yet it
doesn't say it will burn forever because
that's what they get no and yet they
will be saved
um though as by fire
it's almost like this this sense of you
made it but I was a lot burning up yeah
I just barely slipped it in here
um I I think yeah God's God's yes always
follows his his no
and this is why I'm I'm wildly
optimistic about the love of God I'm
wildly optimistic about the second
coming of Jesus and I say Advent is our
great hope and uh so smile
smile it's Advent
um
as we come to the table of the Lord
today
as we take in the body of Christ and the
bread the blood of Christ and the wine
I want us to do it in a spirit of Advent
not a spirit of cringing fear God's out
to get me
uh oh I think I probably have more straw
and grass than diamonds you know but a a
deep loving Trust
that The God Who is up to something in
your life and you're here tonight
so I'm trusting that God is up to
something in your life
that with that trust you can say
come Lord Jesus arrive in my life
and whatever it might be would hay
stubble got burned away start now
burn it away
and let me come to you
with a pure love a pure faith of pure
hope so as you come to the table that's
um that's kind of the heart posture I'd
like us to approach the table with
tonight
so for those unfamiliar this is uh the
bread represents the body of Christ the
wine represents the blood of Christ and
this is a moment where we you know it's
sort of like all the leaders and
everyone here on stage we just kind of
back away and it's just a moment for you
to connect with God
we practice what's called an Open Table
I mean if you're here tonight and you
want to participate then you are free to
do that no one's checking to make sure
you're really saved you know you're you
just come forward
um and then way will come for it is
you'll just kind of go row by Row first
row second row just and so on and so
forth and you're free to just partake
whenever you'd like just that
immediately or you can return to your
seat and take it quietly there so this
is the table
not of the church
but of the Lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith
and you
who have little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come because it's the Lord Jesus who
invites you and it's his will that those
who want to meet him should meet him
here
come to the table
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
you are so good to me
you hear my broken heart
you are my Father in heaven
you are beautiful my sweet sweet song
thank you
I will sing again
[Music]
beautiful my sweet sweet song
you are beautiful my sweet sweet song
I will sing again
[Music]
you are my
strong melodies
[Music]
I will sing of you
forever
[Music]
you poured out all your blood you died
upon the cross
you are my Jesus who loves me
[Music]
by Jesus who loves me you are beautiful
my sweet sweet talk
you are beautiful my sweet sweet song
[Music]
I will sing again
sing again
[Music]
you are my Father in heaven
you are the spirit inside me
[Music]
you were my Jesus who loves me
foreign
thank you so much for being here tonight
thank you for just being able to join us
if you're visiting and it's your first
time here
um we would just like to know who you
are there is um as you're exiting that
door there's a table that has a little
card on the side if you just mind
filling it out just some basic
information we just like to say thank
you for just being here we won't use or
abuse that information we just want to
have record that you're here and just
say thank you
um
as I kind of mentioned before Advent
kind of brings some very interesting
things around the holiday seasons kind
of stir some things up sometimes
um earlier when I was I was reading some
of the things from the prayers of the
people from online I don't know if you
guys were able to hear me because of my
mic stuff but I did see a couple of my
mental health uh prayer race cars that
came across so
um I want to be cognizant of that I also
know just from even just things that we
say in worship things are brought up in
messages it can just stir stuff in us
and we just might need a listening ear
we might need a hug we might need some
and so I'll be standing in the back if
that's something I can you know be that
be that for you before you walk out the
store I want you to feel seen just feel
loved once you feel that you are valued
in this space
um and then with that we want to just
also dismiss you with a blessing do you
want to remind you though before I do
that
or forget this we'll probably do this we
are doing Advent candle lighting service
with Pleasant Valley on uh Christmas Eve
so don't forget about that and then of
course children's ministry is looking
for some help so just kind of keep those
things in the back of your mind anyway
with that being said
if you want to stand and receive this
blessing you can if you want to stay
seated or whatever prostrate you you
feel comfortable in
send you out with this
you are a child of God
and this is true on your best day and
it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
this yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved that you're worthy and you are
accepted Just As You Are
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
the desire to extend these same Gifts of
Greece Grace and unconditional love with
everyone you come in contact with
thank you good night
[Music]